the city mouse and the country
mouse a version of the tale by the Fable
cottage.com
this is a city
mouse he lives in a big city with tall
buildings and lots of shops and
restaurants but today he is visiting his
friend a country
mouse the country mouse lives in a cozy
Nest at the bottom of a
tree her home is small but it is warm
and
comfortable the country mouse Cooks a
dinner of food from her
garden corn carrots
acorns and a cold glass of water from
the
stream meanwhile the city Mouse talks
and
talks the city is a
amazing I go to the theater and the
museum my house has 20 rooms you
absolutely must visit have you ever
tried Chinese
food that night the country mouse dreams
that she lives in the
city she dreams that she eats at fancy
restaurants says fancy things and buys
fancy hats from fancy
stores she dreams about eating Chinese
food how wonderful she thinks I want to
live in the city
[Music]
too the next morning the country mouse
agrees to visit the city
mouse she packs her bag and follows the
city mouse back to his big house in the
city the house is enormous
there are 20 rooms full of beautiful
Furniture the country mouse is
amazed which room is mine she
asks um we actually live down here says
the city mouse he leads her down some
stairs to the
basement in the darkness the country
mouse sees many families of
mice these are my housemates explains
the city mouse the city mouse leads the
country mouse back upstairs for dinner
in the dining room there is a feast of
delicious foods on the
table cheese bread Cookies Cakes and
lemonade there is also Chinese
food but just as they start to
eat crash a cat with sharp teeth and
sharp claws jumps up on the
[Music]
table the city cat Chas faes the two
mice off the table and across the
floor the mice hide in a hole in the
wall they are
trapped they wait silently until the cat
leaves then they quietly creep back to
the dining room but all the food is gone
the city humans ate
everything the country mouse hurries
back to the basement and packs her
bag where where are you going asks the
city
mouse home she says I want to go back to
the country your city life isn't so
wonderful after all now please help me
call a
taxi moral sometimes other people's
lives are not as great as they make you
believe
[Music]